in regards to podcast number 23
in the art of war many of the rules seem
very simplistic
in black and white take this one for
example when the enemy occupies high
ground do not confront him
if he attacks downhill do not oppose him
where does that leave us with battles
like normandy
where troops had to get up those cliffs
what about the idf conquering the golan
golan golan heights golan heights in the
six day war
there are many other examples i could
give it's obviously not ideal to do such
things
as fighting a well-entrenched enemy
uphill but
dealing with less than ideal situations
is a part of war
we should all be so lucky as to only be
able to choose battles that fit the art
of war
but from my experience it's often not an
option in real life
and you have to somehow get it done
anyway
so yeah this is a pretty simple question
with a pretty simple answer too don't
forget
that the laws or the the
the art of war and the and the laws in
the art of war
the rules the simplistic black and white
rules in the in the article
are governed by other rules that say to
break the rules themselves
so so just to pull out a couple quotes i
went and pulled these out sun tzu says
he who can modify his tactics in
relation to his opponent and thereby
succeed in winning
may be called a heaven-born captain
so if you can adapt to the situation
and and adapt your tactics and modify
your tactics
so attacking uphill is a modification of
a tactic right yes
the next one i pulled out sun tzu says
do not repeat tactics that have gained
you one victory
but let your methods be regulated by the
infinite variety of circumstances
that answers the question in its own
right
let your methods be regulated by the
infinite variety of circumstances
and the last little quote i pulled up
from sun tzu
according as circumstances are favorable
one should modify one's plans so there's
three
rules from the art of war
that tell you to change
the rules of the art of war when you
have to
so um yeah you're
told to avoid these situations but
sometimes you have to
now it's also important to remember that
the philosophy of the art of war
generally
espouses an indirect methodology of
combat
aware often times you're trying to
keep yourself safe and inflict damage
when you can
that implies that maybe i have less
physical strength
or size than my opponent so i have less
soldiers or less equipment than my
opponent and from that perspective
let me ask is would it be smart to
attack normandy
if you actually didn't have the the
numbers to carry out the attack
and you didn't have the overwhelming
force that we had amassed on
england to go and assault france
it wouldn't make sense then it would
make sense to continue to
obey the the the principles in the art
of war
which is you know what we're not going
to attack on we're going to figure out
another way to do it
so like i said
these are rules but these are rules like
all rules
that are meant to be broken when the
time calls for it
so good question but it's a it's a
the the art of war answers that question
in itself